le combat pour l'université c'est
vraiment que les universitaires de
bourgogne de franche-comté que
l'université de bourgogne l'université
de franche comté et l'utbm prennent les
moyens de travailler ensemble d'avoir
une voix unique pour défendre notamment
à l'international
le grand problème le grand programme de
labellisation parce que pour l'instant
ça ne marche pas parce qu'aujourd'hui
alors la commune on me dit on me dit
depuis deux mois que les choses
s'améliorent il ya eu un conseil
d'administration de la commue qui est
donc l'établissement qui rassemble nos
trois universités et trop et tous les
établissements universitaires
il y à une amélioration il ya un enjeu
très fort cette université qui est très
forte qui a des laboratoires à la pointe
qui ont un niveau européen de
reconnaissance ils ont un label à
maintenir ça s'appelle la belle visite
je veux pas rentrer dans les détails
techniques derrière c'est beaucoup
d'argent c'est trop d'argent et il faut
vraiment qu'ils arrivent à renouveler
est ce que le fait qu'ils aient du mal à
fonctionner ensemble c'est un petit peu
un effet de la difficulté au bout de
trois ans d'avoir créer quelque chose de
nouveau est ce que c'est ce que 100 mais
un symptôme est ce que vous le voyez
comme ça non l'université a commencé à
travailler ensemble entre bourgogne et
franche-comté bien avant bien avant la
fusion donc ça n'a rien à voir mais il y
a une difficulté intrinsèque ans le voir
pensées de françois rebsamen le maire de
dijon qui lors des journées portes
ouvertes de l'université de franche
comté a fait une campagne de 4 par 3
dans les rues de la ville pour vanter
dijon capitale régionale de l'université
va écouter ce que je pense
évincé la tra chose c'est la traduction
que l'université de bourgogne franche
comté n'est pas à la hauteur de l'enjeu
qui est le sien parce que la campagne
elle devrait être universités bourgogne
franche comté à la fois en interne dans
toute notre région pour dire tout le
potentiel qu'il ya pour les étudiants
dans notre université et surtout elle
devrait être à l'extérieur dans les
régions voisines pour attirer les
étudiants dans notre région parce qu'on
a vraiment des enseignants qui sont top
on a des chercheurs qui sont reconnus au
niveau européen on a des traits vraiment
des très bons atouts au niveau
universitaire et
on ne sait pas aujourd'hui les
communiqués donc moi je m'adresse à
l'université réveillez vous mais
l'université elle le sait je n'ai cessé
depuis trois ans de tenir ce discours
allant même jusqu'à menacer de retirer
des crédits parce que la région amène
des crédits importants à l'université
mais nous ne sommes pas l'âge je suis
sûr que la raison l'emportera mais il
est temps il est temps